alors on a un ancien policier de la bac
avec nous aujourd'hui instructeur de
police raul merci d'être là alors vous
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous êtes fait
agresser il ya moins d'un an le soir en
rentrant chez vous qu'est ce qui s'est
passé que j'entrais j'étais équiper en
moteurs parce que je rentrais à moto et
ont fini en beauté vous étiez vous étiez
en nous je n'entends pas d'uniforme jeu
maintenu motards soient tenus de motards
en civil en retard donc dans mon casque
et gants et donc j'ai géré rejoindre
hall d'entrée et il faut savoir que là
où je vis le meuble est constamment
squatté par des individus qui profite de
l'entrée dans mon rôle pour dit les
uriner et déféquer parcomètres plainte
d'un pain de dégradation et donc ça fait
des mois que ça dure personne ne bouge
et quand je suis rentré dans mon rôle
j'en ai surpris quatre qui étaient là et
j'ai remarqué une une flaque d'uriné
donc je leur ai demandé les ayant
identifié comme n'habitant pas dans
l'immeuble je leur ai demandé de sortir
il est bon les gars je sais que vous
n'habitez pas ici vous sortez donc là je
me suis fait insulter
on nous a été quitte où on va te
défoncer enlève son casque et il faut
savoir que moi je garde mon casque
puisque je suis connu comme étant
policiers dans la dent dans mon immeuble
par la cité d'en face en fait j'ai eu
maille à partir
souvent avec les individus qui vivent et
donc bon ils connaissent le gars avec le
casque blanc qui arrive à moto ils
savent très bien que je suis est donc
j'ai subi des insultes pas de coups gt4
mais bon ils n'ont pas décidé de me
sauter dessus
donc j'ai réussi à les faire sortir une
fois que la porte a été fermé c'est une
porte qui se bloquent magnétiquement
donc assez solide j'ai été appelé mon
ascenseur et la 30 secondes après j'ai
entendu frapper violemment à la porte
avec des mecs qui le relaient donc j'ai
regardé et là j'ai vu qu'ils avaient une
dizaine douzaine de mecs qui étaient en
train de mettre des coups de poing des
coups de pieds en disant on va te [ __ ]
nazis salt salle coeur on va te maraver
je sais vraiment les mots qu'était
mathieu relancer et donc moi je me suis
dit bon de toute façon la porte est
fermée ils sont bloqués même s'il
frappait violemment dans la porte à la
tenue et j'attendais mon ascenseur le
problème c'est que une locataire est
arrivé petite dame gentil comme tout
mais bon voyant les individus excité sur
la porte a insulté qui n'insulte jamais
entendu dire moi je veux juste rentrer
chez moi donc elle a actionné le bipe la
porte s'est ouverte et là les gars se
sont rencontrés et bah je savais ce qui
allait m'arriver donc l'ascenseur
n'était arrivé il a aussi mis dos à
l'ascenseur
tout de suite c'est dans ma tête c'était
très vite me suis dit qu'est-ce qu'il
faut que je fasse si je si je commence à
frapper le problème c'est qu'ils vont
mettre au sol et y vont aussi de
m'arracher mon casque donc j'ai pensé à
tout de suite attrapé la jugulaire de
mon casque pour éviter de faire arraché
le casque
j'ai bien fait puisque j'ai subi une
pluie de coups de poing coups de pied
dont je suis tombé au sol avec un d un
des gars que j'ai agrippé avec un drap
mais j'ai essayé de maintenir mais pas
de mon casque et j'ai bien fait puisque
80% des coûts que j'ai pris et est dans
la tête et j'ai senti tout de suite
qu'ils ont essayé d'arracher le casque
donc là des coups de pied dans le dans
le corps dans la dans la tête et j'ai
basculé en fait ce qu'il ya un petit
escalier qui mène à l'ascenseur de cinq
marches j'ai basculé lourdement sur le
dos donc avec un individu heureusement
que j'avais la dorsale je n'ai senti
passer quand même
et là bas au sol j'ai continué à prendre
des coups et à un moment donné j'ai eu
un flash dans le casque et je me suis
rendu compte que 1 des gars on avait
sauté à pieds joints sur la tête du haut
des escaliers et ça à trois reprises
voilà donc le casque intégral il est
mort il est enfoncé bon j'ai pas pu le
ramener malheureusement mais voilà donc
il ya moins d'un an moyens non un an
puisque là c'est moi vous habitez
toujours dans le rouge habite toujours
la wii et moi une forme je vais
déménager je vais partir d'accord mais
vous les avez revu vous avez je les vois
quotidiennement puisqu'en fait quand je
rentre chez moi je me fais siffler
je vous fais insulter voilà ils savent
très bien que je suis malgré les
rapports à ma hiérarchie la semaine vous
allez vous avez dit un truc qui a dû
interpeller tout le monde ici sur ce
plateau et les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent en direct vous avez dit dans
cet immeuble il ya des gens qui sont là
qui n'ont rien à y faire
qui font du trafic qui défèquent du rib
raison qu'est on l'a dit cent fois et
haché mais rien eu de fait alors que
vous êtes fait partie des forces de
l'ordre ça vous imaginez le message que
vous envoyer aux téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent et qui disent nous on
fait pas partie de la police oui on dit
qu'il ya rien de fait mais quand un
policier vous dit il n'y a rien de fait
alors que moi je fais partie de la
police et donc je n'arrive pas à faire
bouger les choses
là je peux vous dire les gens la f10
bombe alors personne ne peut rien faire
on est dans une impasse mais il est bien
là les tchèques cyril c'est que les
premières victimes de l'insécurité ses
habitants des quartiers populaires
la sécurité c'est la première des
libertés elle est même pas garantie dans
ces quartiers là il est bien là l'échec
et moi je ne réalisais pas l'échec de la
politique et de la société
je ne suis pas dans les causes de
phyllis et je suis gentil flic avant
qu'on donc avant qu'on glisse une telle
échelle a bien été de les décrire
je l'avais dit la dernière fois sur ce
plateau - j'ai au contraire je demande à
ce qu'ils aient plus de 2,2 d'effectifs
qu'on donne les moyens à la police et
que et que je rêve de cette scène le 11
janvier 2015 le jour de la marche
républicaine où tout le monde a fait de
mal et les flics et malo et mais
j'aimerais qu'on vienne juste sur ce que
nous a dit raul raul
quand vous dites rien n'a été fait quand
vous pouvez nous dire si vous êtes
policier
vous avez eu qu'est ce que vous pouvez
dire aux gens qui vous entendre dire que
rien n'est fait et quand vous êtes chez
eux c'est pareil ils disent nous on
n'est pas policiers n'arrivent pas à
faire bouger les choses les policiers
non plus c'est très simple le problème
c'est déjà moi quand j'ai
j'ai appelé la police à de nombreuses
reprises bon ils se sont parfois
déplacée parce que mon écran qu'ils ont
du travail des effectifs réduits
quand je vois une petite voiture de
doses de trois fonctionnaires qui arrive
de jaune fonctionnaires confrontés à un
individu déterminé on sait très bien
comment ça va se passer je comprends les
collectes donc une parodie aller au
contact ce qu'ils vont faire et pour ce
faire m mais comme mesures est en fait
c'est tellement sensible politiquement
vous imaginez un policier qui sort ils
sont ils sont dépassés par le nombre
un prompteur sort son arme utilise son
arme vous imaginez les conséquences que
cela peut avoir donc les policiers sur
courant de ça ils sont inhibés inhibé
parce que il y vient faire le boulot le
témoignage de raul c impunité oui voilà
il jouera sentiment qu'ils ont ils ont
un sentiment d'impunité est d'ailleurs
la preuve je veux dire sur les individus
qui ont été interpellés y en a 3 sur les
douze qui me sont tombés dessus elle a
deux qui étaient mineurs
vous allez voir comment vous allez
déposer plainte mais bon c'était classé
sans suite et pas de nom mais c'est
incroyable que la façon d une part les
roses dit je vous dis donc ça d'ailleurs
aimé c'est pas la première fois que ça
m'arrive à voilà donc et puis je suis
pas le seul point ici plein doute un des
serveurs et ça passe ou tout simplement
sur les incivilités à l'origine moi je
l'attendais antoine on engage des
insultes mais pas du bon les gars vous
dégager d'ici ça suffit quoi le mais le
mec il ya du ring dans le couloir c'est
loin des choses et manon encore on avait
resserré stabilité c'est moi le méchant
qui leur demande de partir j'avais ces
deux heures par les mêmes à résidence
imposée déraisonnée maintenant que c'est
impossible c'est impossible le dialogue
est rompu depuis des années puisque moi
j'ai déjà le même réservoir est ce que
c'est vrai que quand on est en manque
comme ça mais un par un ils sont on ne
peut pas les voir ils sont toujours en
groupe
impossible ces temps-ci policiers ont
obligé des ménages est obligé de
déménager des enfants de policiers qui
ne peuvent pas dire que leurs parents
sont policiers
en fait la peur a changé de camp mais
même temps le havre et des effectifs
demeurent quant à leur ya une forme
d'abandon
bien sûr parce que comme la réponse
judiciaire ne suit pas on en a encore
l'exemple là et qui a aussi beaucoup de
mineurs on en a parlé la dernière fois
la majorité pénale à 16 ans bien sûr que
quand les policiers arrêtent des gens et
qui ressorte immédiatement sans sanction
il ya un mot moyenne tente de lassitude
et donc on laisse faire ce et des zones
de non droit il ya plein de sites et où
les policiers ne peuvent plus rentrer ça
c'est une employée des effectifs en
nombre et reprenait
je ne vous êtes pas tard je récupère un
immeuble
je suis désolé mais vous servir des
quartiers n'existe plus non évoluer pas
dans le bon sens elle a évolué je te
cite un exemple que j'ai connus - du
temps du préfet du 93
christian lambert il a fait une
opération comme aux beaudottes à sevran
où il a mis une compagnie crs dans
chaque hall d'immeuble mais c'est sûr il
ya plus de problèmes à une compagnie de
crs c'est quand le nombre de quartiers
politique de la ville et qui en france
1300 à 1500 jaurès et +17 l'aider et
fait même et ses 5000 ou de sa vie de la
cité par tam tam driss et prenez vos
doigts du tout raisonnable vidéo du
rappeur qui étaient arrêtés contre
lequel d'ailleurs j'ai rien plus un très
bon musicien yann dampha une femme qui
dit vous êtes 4 sur un même si le combat
devait être à la loyale et ensuite le
rappeur dit on va être de dommages ou
pan de mur et oui il la police n'a pas à
faire deux choses à la loyale
elle incarne la légalité ça n'a rien à
voir raul surtout quand on parle de ce
surnom pour les policiers mais le
surnombre
il est on dit tout moi quand je forme
mes stagiaires jordi vous devez vous
assurer du sûrement pourquoi c'est une
garantie de protection pour les
policiers mais aussi pour l'interpeller
il faut le manioc le maîtriser le plus
vite possible pour lui entraver sa
liberté de mouvement et éviter qu'il se
passe quelque chose que je comprends pas
dans votre témoignage les individus s'en
sont pris à vous en tant que policier
vous avez été identifiés avaient drainé
moi tu as presque cessé un délit grave
is in de s'en prendre violemment aux
terres là voilà comment se fait-il que
ça soit s'en suit alors c'est un délit
grave ici c'est parce que ce n'est guère
que l'étiquette que j'ai les gars et les
trois contrats privés de mineurs sait-on
d'accord maintenant et je suis pas
persuadé que si le lit majeur avait été
interpellé sans appel à la loi c'est pas
du tout la leur c'est classique